hey youtubers it's Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's Korra Q&A good news too I'm
actually glad I waited a couple days
because we just found out about the
latest comic that's gonna be coming out
it'll actually be next year careful for
spoilers so if you're not cut up on the
episodes starting with questions so
number one great is ask
I think kuvira is going to try and
destroy the Banyan Grove tree and Korra
will somehow have to energy Bend herself
to become the new center of balance
between the spirit world in the real
world which may reconnect her to her
past lives or make her into a kind of
lion turtle figure so there is a
possibility that somehow she could
separate herself from her physical body
like she is now or it could be like a
book one situation where like Princess
Yu a she has to give back the energy
that was given to her a la raba to
replace what was lost by the tree I
don't think necessarily that returning
things during launch time would be
balanced though because there was a lot
of class inequality at that time and now
we're starting to get into the idea of
democracy like with president break oh
and the United Republic I do think
they'll be like a really sad ending I
don't know if Korra will die that's
definitely still a high possibility like
she could sacrifice herself somehow but
I don't think completely taking away
bending is the answer I would totally
lose my [ __ ] if she brought the lion
Turtles back somehow as far as we know
they've completely died off I don't
think that we ever really got an answer
about what happened to the one we saw
during Avatar book four I was kind of
hoping to see that again
during Korra so fingers crossed for Lion
Turtles question number two amory s is
the sky bison that opal Lin and Bolin
taking sick
it looks pretty sick yes yeah like it
has all the junk coming out of its nose
and I think it has something to do with
what's going on between the balance
between the spirit world in the real
world they'll probably explain that in
the next episode though things are kind
of wonky between the spiritual world and
the physical world and we've seen the
spiritual consequences of that spirit
wilds going crazy and like the vines
taking people I think the sky bison
getting sick is that manifesting in the
real world there's no way they would
make it look that sick with that big of
a runny nose without something really
really being wrong question number three
Lupita asks his Korra able to lava bend
as well do you think anyone is gonna die
before the show ends big questions ok so
Korra yes Korra can do any type of
bending she just has to learn the
technique as four people die
I would say if there's a good chance of
people dying it would be original avatar
characters as well as Cora herself the
interesting thing about Cora
metalbending and like doing all the sub
styles is that it's really just a matter
of her putting in the homework as we've
seen the homework not really her strong
suit
like it was really hard for her to learn
how to airbend it's very much like a
metaphysical thing so it requires court
to go to this really mental place and of
all the things that have been really
messed up with her in the last four
books her head has been the most messed
up if her disconnection from raava is
any example then even a minor mental
block is enough to completely cut her
off from her bending abilities and when
you really think about it energy bending
should be the most difficult style and
she actually seems to have a pretty easy
time energy bending the reason they
explained that she didn't do it whenever
she was fighting kuvira's because she
was just trying to choose the rational
path question number four Cameron asks
why do you think that Sahir didn't try
to use airbending while he was in Chains
I would say they probably just made the
change too strong for him to break just
from a logic standpoint you know without
trying to overanalyze things too much
they wanted to hear to be stuck in
prison so whatever the story required
for him to be stuck in there like they
would have invented that like that's the
explanation and he's such a spiritual
person he lost Polly that now he's
probably just super Zen all the time
like he probably spends as much time as
possible inside the spirit world so his
physical body doesn't matter quite so
much although to be fair he cannot bend
in the spirit world
whereas Korra can as we've learned now
that's actually a significant reversal
on Canon or maybe you could look at it
from the perspective of them just not
fully explaining it before that's always
an interesting thing too we could spend
like a whole other video talking about
you know the way they explained the
logic they haven't pulled the rug out
from under us too much but when you
think about it it's possible for some of
these characters to be unreliable
narrators maybe even an avatar like
cores an avatar so if she has a
misconception about something in explain
to someone else then we'll get the wrong
idea about it because you kind of
automatically assumes that the avatar
knows everything especially if it's one
of the past lives one of the older
avatars like Avatar Roku it would be
interesting to see Zaheer let out of
that prison I mean he is very powerful I
would think that if anyone was gonna die
in the finale
that was not Korra it would be someone
that Zaheer killed and I think if they
did let him out he would actually just
go after Koo beer and try to kill her
that would actually be a pretty badass
fight kuvira versus Zaheer question
number five
Dave s do you think the top will fight
kuvira for taking spirit vines I do
think there'll be some sort of conflict
I mean Toph walks up in the teaser so
clearly they're going to have some sort
of battle between the BEI Fong family
and kuvira's army I think what we'd see
is Toph take out like a large section of
their army she's so powerful I mean she
is like a club
beifong would be more like the knife
like she's not quite as powerful as Toph
so she would probably be the one to run
in Toph would probably be like their
linebacker like she would just run at
the defense so that it distracted
everyone and the rest of them could slip
in and steal the family so if we see
anything from Toph I think it will be
like some giant distraction as awesome
as it would be to see her fight kuvira
directly it'd be more personal to see
soohyun fight kuvira so if anyone
actually fights kuvira directly I think
it'll be su Yin she is kind of like
soohyun's daughter in a way so it's much
more cat's in the cradle question number
six PC guy asks what about Asami's
father he's a genius too I assume you're
talking about helping fight kuvira yes I
do think he'll give them some advice
from inside prison I don't think they'll
let him out like he'll stuff to serve
his sentence out but I do think I'll
help we've only seen a little bit from
Asami's father but I think that he'll
probably provide like some small
technical advice that will help them
solve their problem asami and varrick
might hit a wall like with some sort of
equation or some sort of device and
he'll just provide the solution to that
I've said it before but I think it's
just gonna be a more advanced version of
what Varrick did whenever they were
escaping the earth Kingdom like a giant
EMP something to take out their entire
army at the same time cuz kuvira has a
shitload of mechs the other really cool
solution would be like some badass Chain
Lightning I'm gonna go ahead and guess
that all those mechs are not made out of
non conductive metal although I would
not be surprised if they did have a
little bit of platinum in him just as a
defense mechanism against other metal
benders question seven full-time slacker
asks if zoomy has all the political
power
what exactly does Zuko do anymore
besides be a reference to Last Airbender
well that's harsh no Zuko is more of a
White Lotus figure now and when I say
White Lotus business I mean I'm mostly
talking about spiritual matters like big
big world problems that don't
necessarily just involve the Fire Nation
I think he's on the same path
he's not quite as spiritual as Iroh was
though like not quite as wise yet we
briefly saw him during the earth Kings
coronation he didn't have any speaking
lines but hopefully he comes back with
the dragon with rook I would like to
like to see some dragon eggs before the
end of the series but they might say
that for the comics question eight
Jessica asks what do you think the
spirit vines are trying to do to the
people that they took
what's with the spirit pod things I'm
actually guessing that it was all a
mechanism to get Korra to fix herself
I'm sure they'll explain it better
whenever the DVD commentary is released
they think Mike and Bryan always record
DVD commentaries and explain everything
in really great detail but I'm guessing
that the spirits did it as a big call to
action to Korra like it was all about
Korra otherwise they would have taken a
lot of people there is a small chance
that they were somehow feeding on the
energy inside people it's such a weird
thing that I do think that they'll
explain it in the next couple of
episodes though like it seems like too
big of a thing to just brush over
question nine Aakash asks what happened
to Julie she's still working on that big
weapon with Betar jr. I think by the
time we see Cuvier again back in the
swamp like not with a vision like
actually see her there the weapon will
be done so that's when we'll see Julie
again I'm hoping to get some more
context some more lines from her that
spell out whether or not she really did
turn on barek or if she's running some
sort of inside job she went from almost
making out with him big time to like
hardcore hating him within an episode I
just I feel like that's too quick of a
turn for it to be completely genuine I
feel like she's running some sort of
long con on kuvira question number 10
Korey asks if you could hang out with
any Legend of Korra character who would
it be I guess I would depend on what I
was trying to do you know if I had
enough coffee like if I was caffeinated
I would totally hang out with Bolin
otherwise he would totally drain all my
energy otherwise I would say you know
maybe Asami Asami feels like one of the
more interesting characters now just to
justify my Pig you know yeah Korra is
the most powerful character she's super
cool but think about it this way the
avatar is like completely disconnected
from pop culture and if you wanted to
hang out with someone you probably
talked about like what was going on in
the world things were cool like cool
bands
cool games Korra is completely
disconnected from that right now she's
been out to lunch for like three years
so she would not really have that many
interesting things to say now if you
wanted to say
gout like she'd be amazing like she'd be
an awesome workout partner but if you
just wanted to chill out asami is
probably the smartest character on the
show thank you so much everyone for so
many questions as you're always a ton of
fun to do remember okay
really important date December 19th
two-part finale I may have set a
different date in one of my other videos
but it's basically like a new episode
every week you know or basically episode
10 and then a week after that episode 11
and then two episodes it's the same time
every season they always do two episodes
at the very end so there'll be a couple
more weeks of regular bonus videos be
sure to subscribe to get everything
which actually reminds me
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner garrett williams you in the
Amazon giftcard it just message me on my
channel for details you basically win a
$20 Amazon gift card so again
just quick reminder on the comic book
coming out September 23rd 2015 I know
that's a long ways away they said
they've already talked about the next
couple comics they they kind of have an
idea about what kind of stories they
want to do but it just means that there
will be more Dark Horse Comics so
whenever it does roll around to next
year that first smoke and shadow comic
it'll just be part one part one of three
so everybody breathe easy I'll totally
do a separate bonus video about it they
did not say anything about a Legend of
Korra comic but that's probably on the
table and just real quick reminder new
mobile links up here if you're in your
mobile phone or on your tablet or
somewhere else you can click on this
it's the same as the links over here but
right now click here for my episode 9
video and click here for my episode 8
video thank you so much for watching so
let's all high-five I will see you guys
tonight
you